Oh God last time what are they big
they're huge and they big they're so big
I don't ever shop online
I love Amazon I'm not trying to get a
sponsor here but I think they're great I
think that's a great company I don't
know what to expect here you can find
anything you need there I literally I
bought something on Amazon before we
started filming I'm not nervous because
I have the gut of a raccoon giant water
bugs the one thing I don't want to do is
eat bugs salted cooked and dehydrated so
they're prepared there's two GU bugs in
that big package I thought is there a
little preservative things on it my
eyeballs are still on there Oh
oh there's like a pretzel
oh the taste is actually not bad it's
very savory with sabi gumballs it's a
quick burn that's the nice thing about
wasabi these look cute you know they're
tiny yes can you go first
oh hello hard okay um I'm feeling the
flavor now oh it's a little bit spicy
it really just tastes like you had some
asabi after having done that Mike's hot
honey that sounds like his girlfriend
hey you got my hot honey you'll get my
hot honey over here
she's sweet dudes clover honey there's
wildflower honey there's a lot of
different kinds and they're all
beautiful in there a little way when you
have a cold you want spicy food and you
want honey I don't I don't get the
market for this
oh I see I'm not mad about this I like
it for things were they thinking I like
pork so I think I will like it but it's
weird also how much like brains is it
gonna look liquidy yeah look at it look
at the little brains like really tender
spam 1000 60% cholesterol well good
morning
I'm gonna get my thousand percent of
cholesterol today earthworm jerky I've
always wanted to eat her thorns
I have eaten no library oh you have yeah
okay smoked paprika powder garlic powder
onion powder red chili spices vinegar
and salt actually some pretty good Oh
cuz they look like wool turds that's why
we go that's a good one hard to shoot
hard Biden's very very very chewy these
are sharp - oh this tastes like stale
gym clothes this food was so diverse I
feel like my body is going through some
weird changes right now you know what
the internet is an amazing place full of
wonderful weird things and terrible
horrifying things yeah you can have all
of them come in with no gravy gravy
[Music]